the White House has finally put in place
new so-called rules for reporters who
want to be in the press room during
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is now very
infrequent press briefings and the new
rules can be used to kick out almost the
entire press corps if that's what the
White House decides it wants to do
there's something called a hard pass to
the press room okay a hard pass is good
for two years and it gets reporters in
the press room and on White House
grounds
the White House doesn't want as many
people to have these two year passes
because if Joe the reporter or Sally the
correspondent asked a question that the
White House doesn't like in month one of
their hard Pass tenure the White House
now needs to deal with this adversarial
person that they don't like for twenty
three more months until their hard pass
expires so what the White House is doing
is making it much harder to obtain or to
keep those hard passes if they're
claiming it's all for security reasons
you'd have to be a [ __ ] to believe that
that's the case because if someone is
really a security threat the Secret
Service and the Capitol Police can
easily say they need to be removed even
though they have a hard pass because
they are a security concern so the new
rule is that reporters have to enter the
White House at least 50% of the days
over the hundred and eighty day period
leading up to the renewal which
basically means every other day but
there are not actually that many days
during that hundred and eighty day
period that those reporters would
potentially be going to the White House
and I'll explain because you might think
well there's a hundred and eighty days
the reporter needs to be there for 90 of
them maybe but if you are a White House
reporter for the most part things are
happening at the White House in terms of
briefings only on weekdays so you're 180
days to seven to seven of those hundred
and eighty days or weekends so that
already kind of gets you down to only
128 weekdays so you've got to be there
90 days out of a hundred and
twenty-eight weekdays so that means you
need to be at the White House
70% of
the days not 50% of the days but if
you're part of the press corps the press
corps often travels with the president
and once you start putting together
these multi day trips plus some of the
even longer ones that the press corps
attends to say that they have to be
there 50% of the day's ends up working
out to a huge majority of all the
weekdays that the president is not
traveling and this is a ridiculous
requirement and to go even further
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is barely doing
briefings these days she has had two
news briefings this year since January 1
2019
she went 59 days without a briefing so
you're putting in place a requirement
for reporters to have to go to the White
House on the overwhelming majority of
weekdays during which the president is
not traveling even though they're not
doing briefings and there's no practical
reason to be there also that they can
say you don't qualify to renew your hard
pass and if you lose your hard pass you
need to either get a daily pass or a
weekly pass or try to get a six-month
pass and right away you become subject
to the political whims of the White
House whether they do or don't like your
reporting
CNN's Jim Acosta sort of a perfect
example the Washington Post's Dana
Millbank has had his pass revoked this
week was notified via email says that
there are other reporters including all
seven of the Washington Post's white
house correspondents and we know that
Donald Trump doesn't like the Washington
Post politically so this is obviously
politically motivated it is yet another
way in which a Republican administration
that says they're for transparency and
says they are for all of the BS that the
write likes to claim to be for they are
actually one of the most authoritarian
anti media administration's that we've
seen and meanwhile they continue to
launch attacks on the left claiming it's
the left who wants to suppress speech
that it's the left who doesn't want the
real hard questions asked and all of
this other nonsense that they're using
to bamboozle voters around the country
extraordinarily heavy-handed anti media
speech pro censorship decisions and if
you believe that this is all about
security concerns I feel sorry for you
I don't know what kind of a fantasy
world you're living in that you buy that
explanation from the White House
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show follow us
both if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video